Au début du confinement, on a tous fait des réserves, que l’on a mises au frais…
Mais après plusieurs jours dans le réfrigérateur,
les bananes sont devenues toutes noires…
En façade seulement !
La couleur de la banane est due à des substances
qu’on appelle les phénols.
La banane est un fruit tropical qui, une fois qu’elle a commencé à murir, ne supporte pas le froid.
En dessous de 10-12°C,
les cellules qui composent la peau se dégradent.
La peau se ramollit. Les cellules sont moins étanches…
Des substances – jusque-là séparées – se combinent
C’est le cas de l’oxygène contenu dans l’air, une enzyme et les fameux phénols.
Un nouveau composé apparait
qui ressemble à la mélanine,
vous savez, ces petits grains qui font brunir la peau quand on prend le soleil.
La banane bronze pour se protéger.
A l’intérieur, la chair qui contient beaucoup
moins de phénols
reste blanche et parfaitement digeste
comme cette « capsule de déconfiné ».
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes tous confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour. Alors pour
ne rater aucune de ces "capsules de déconfiné",
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...